faudra-t-il travailler plus pour
reconstruire l'économie laminée par le
commis de 10,9 au fil de ses
interventions
emmanuel macron semble le penser mais
n'y at-il pas un paradoxe a demandé aux
français de travailler plus alors que le
chômage monte lui en flèche
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex de
nos studios de caumartin bonsoir jacques
bonsoir c'est fanny alors jacques le
président maquereau a récemment rappelé
que les français étaient parmi ceux en
europe qui y travaillaient le moins que
faut-il penser de son injonction a
travaillé plus là stéphanie c'est
effectivement un espèce de lieux communs
qui a repris le président macron les
français travailleraient moins que leurs
voisins et surtout moins longtemps que
nos voisins ce n'est pas exactement ce
que disent des chiffres pareils on peut
se demander si le problème n'est pas que
les français travaillent peut être mieux
qu'un certain nombre d'autres
et puis la troisième question c'est
évidemment celle du rapport avec la
montée du chômage que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est ce que ça a vraiment un
sens de dire qu'il faut travailler plus
quand on a de plus en plus de chômeurs
angeac qu'en est il des chiffres alors
stéphanie vous savez l'oscd ne tient
justement des statistiques régulières
sur cette question et on voit que les
français qui sont connus pour bénéficier
effectivement des 35 heures
1 un certain nombre de congés payés et
bien c'est français il travaille
beaucoup regardé justement ces
statistiques
vous me voyez les français travaillent
plus que les allemands que les
néerlandais vous savez ces gens de
l'europe du nord que l'on dit justement
très travailleur banon les français
travaillent plus
par contre il travaille peut-être un
petit peu moins que les italiens ou les
espagnols alors jacques qu'en est-il au
sens la population française alors vous
avez tout à fait raison de poser cette
question stéphanie parce qu'on voit bien
que suivant les professions la durée du
travail varie beaucoup
prenons par exemple le cas des
agriculteurs les agriculteurs
travaillent pratiquement 60 heures par
semaine
les professions libérales les artisans
les petits chefs d'entreprises
travaillent eux aussi beaucoup bon même
les ouvriers et les employés travaillent
sensiblement plus que 35 heures par
semaine
donc il faut comprendre que 35 heures
c'est une durée légale mais que la durée
réelle du travail
elle est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
proche de 40 heures alors junte est-il
vrai comme l'affirmé emmanuel macron que
les français travaillent moins longtemps
sur l'ensemble de leur carrière
alors ça c'est fini ça pose la question
de ce qu'on appelle le taux d'activité
pour la tranche d'âge de 55 à 64 ans et
là encore l'oscd le tient des
statistiques qui sont particulièrement
précises
si vous regardez les chiffres vous
constatez que les français sont un peu
de choses près au même niveau que
justement les italiens les espagnols
par contre il ya effectivement quelques
pays en particulier la des pays d'europe
du nord comme les pays bas ou
l'allemagne où ce taux d'activité est
plus élevé alors comment expliquez vous
cela
et bien en réalité stéphanie ce que l'on
voit là c'est tout simplement l'effet du
chômage
en effet le chômage on le sait il touche
soit les jeunes qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail et qu'il n'arrive pas
justement à rentrer sur le marché du
travail soient les plus de 50 ans où les
plus de 55 ans qui sont parmi les
premiers qui sont licenciés et c'est
très exactement ce qui fait la
différence aujourd'hui entre la france
et des pays comme les pays bas ou
l'allemagne
c'est l'importance du chômage en france
qui pousse les entreprises
justement à licencier ou ois poussé vers
des mises à la retraite anticipée tous
les personnels qui ont plus de 55 ans il
devient en france extrêmement dur de
trouver du travail quand on est
considéré comme un travailleur seniors
alors nouveau la ramener au problème du
chômage d'où notre question de départ
dans un pays qui a plus de 11 % de
chômeurs suivant l insee
est-ce que cela a un sens de dire aux
gens justement qu'il faut travailler
davantage
évidemment non stéphanie évidemment non
si vous voulez le problème c'est que si
on veut que les gens de plus de 55 ans
travaille plus et travaillent plus
longtemps surtout il faut leur donner du
travail
or nous sommes justement dans une
situation que celle inverse où il y a
moins de travail pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui les entreprises elle parle
de quoi elle parle de plans sociaux
elle parle de licencier pas d'embauché
donc on voit très bien il n'y a pas de
sens à dire il faut travailler plus
longtemps alors oui si l'on pose
peut-être la question de manière un peu
différente
alors justement quelle signification
pardon jacques j'étais impatient de
savoir quelle signification cachée tout
à fait vous aviez raison d'être
impatient parce que qu'est-ce qui va se
jouer par exemple admettons que de par
la loi
on repousse la durée légale du travail à
65 ans à 66 ans c'est pas pour autant
que les gens vont travailler plus en
fait
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui sera mis au
chômage à 60 61 62 63 ans
et bien il ne touchera pas sa retraite
complète
il aura ce qu'on appelle une décote et
on peut se demander si ce n'est pas cela
que vise en réalité
emmanuel macron autrement dit non pas
faire travailler plus les gens il n'en a
pas les moyens
puisque nous sommes dans une situation
où le chômage augmente mais bien de
diminuer les pensions de retraite
l art en conclusion jacques vous pensez
que c'est la seule raison
alors c'est en tous les cas la seule
raison qui serait rationnel
mettons de côté évidemment la
possibilité que ce ne soit qu'un thèmes
idéologiques
la seule raison qui aujourd'hui est
rationnel c'est que le gouvernement veut
faire baisser les pensions de retraite
il veut en réalité finir de mettre en
oeuvre cette fameuse réforme des
retraites qu'il a dû interrompre le
temps de l'épidémie ducobu 19 et que ce
soit emmanuel macron par exemple dans
son interview la presse quotidienne
régionale
où que ce soit jean castex
les deux ont dit qu'ils voulaient la
reprendre en réalité on voit bien ce qui
est en jeu aujourd'hui c'est une baisse
des pensions de retraite et bien jacques
si on comprend bien il va falloir se
retrousser les manches
merci à vous et à bientôt sur rt france